je vous pose la question mineure on voit
des scansions sur tf1 même en access
prime time même toute la journée je vois
les grandes vacances là les meilleures
vacances et c'est aussi à votre époque
des scores comme ça pasqua alors
lorsqu'un patron était alors là c'était
impossible ça on le sait moi j'ai vécu
dix noms aller à mon époque et c'est de
débarrasser ne te fait pas 30 ans mais
en aiguille 40 ménagères pour dire aux
gens déjà franchement tu étais tu étais
pas bien donc avec ces scores las je
vois pas comment ils vont continuer de
sévir et dès lundi les gens et éviter
l'accident industriel
et là il ya un vrai bon oeil qui va
commencer à se poser c'est que pour le
groupe bouygues tf1 qui avant était et
est une pépite pépite d'or aux rimes à
temps pour le groupe bouygues
c'est une petite enquête dans la
chaussure donc l'album est oui et de vol
nick matthew taux qui connaît bien la
télé dit la vérité stop ou encore et
d'efforts comme ça alors c'est marx
quand je faisais quand benjamin animé
donc effectivement langues de vip sur
tf1 la première effet 38 du 40 ménagères
la deuxième c'est un tout petit peu et
moi j'arrive j'avais une jolie voiture
que j'arrive avec ma voiture et je fais
directeur des magazines s'appelle
nicolas ya ce nom l'émission était passé
à 28 et 38 au vraiment des heures que je
lutterai rêver il m'a regardé mais bien
là de leurs maux il s'attend la voiture
je serais toi vu les scores la biture à
toi c'est énorme
et effectivement on était à 28,38 et
c'était déjà déjà ça comment voulez vous
voulez je vous raconte un truc moi
vraiment c'est un truc que j'ai jamais
dit un moment j'ai fait contacter tf1
par d'autres équipes comme moi puisque
je les contacte pas directement ce qu'on
n'est pas voilà on n'est pas y est je
leur avais proposé
je vous jure que c'est vrai de relance
est à prendre ou à laisser avec arthur 1
et que je produise le jeu pas qu on dise
mais je vois là et ils ont refusé et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vu les scores
d'apprendre les c'est parce que je pense
que sur tf1 un retour d'apprendre
laisser son rack et un mas a vu surtout
qu'aujourd'hui je vois qu'on accepte ils
sont à deux millions deux millions trois
à tout casser avant le vrai et c'est
vrai qu'ils ont fait du one man show
furie à moi je serai pas enfin je pense
que c'est aussi parce que vous animez la
cmm adnane mais vraiment je sais que
tout autour de nous on le dit arthur de
toute façon ça commence à être un petit
peu dépassé voit la fin même si je les
aime beaucoup il ya un contenu mais
honnêtement je pense que c'est vous qui
faites un peu la marque grannies c'est
pour ça
non non pas du tout le monde sait que
cet appel à nous n'a su sur deux têtes
la mettez un amour et on respecte le
public système et non mais c'est vrai
nom mais vous savez je leur ai proposé
ce que vous pensez qu'ils ont fait une
erreur ou pas maintenant je pense déjà
il faut il faut être très honnête parle
de jules dieu sait si j'ai un courbet
sais c'est qu'une personne que j'admire
et ken carrière si j'en ai le tir un
jour je serai heureux quand il l'a
relancé effectivement lui sur ses huit
ça n'avait pas les scores que ça encore
aujourd'hui je pense qu'effectivement
mais sûre en tout cas sur cette chaîne
c'est un peu voilà c'est un petit peu
avec vous je suis pas sûr à chaque fois
qu'on a tenté de relancer quelque chose
de vieux ça n'a jamais jamais jamais
fonctionné dont je pense même pas du
tout je suis pas d'accord je suis là
avec et de chavannes ça a été un carton
et dons et prêts à 12h30 je te prie avec
la gare n'importe quoi là la caf à 10
ans était prêt à porter quoi